Speaker 1: Why don't we try? Oh,
I don't know. Maybe. Emily from Colorado.
Emily from Colorado. Welcome to the program.
Emily from Colorado. I've invited you in.
Speaker 4: Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine, Emily. Thank you.
Speaker 4: All right. I hope
your day is going well.
Speaker 1: It's going well. Thanks.
Speaker 4: So lying. Let's talk about lying. Sure.
Politicians have always done this forever. But
with Trump, it became this sort of comical like
spectator sport and some kind of robot who can't
be destroyed and only gains power through lies. He
was president, but now we have Congressman Jorge
Santos, boxing world champion and tallest man
alive. Yeah, other accolades. And he's lying a
lot and really badly. Right. And it's about his
credentials and his identity and it's getting a
lot of attention. And people are calling for his
resignation. But no one's making him resign. No.
And so my question is like, how is there no way
to make him resign? I know a law that says if you
lie to the American people that you're fired.
Speaker 1: What if? Well, that would be a very
hard that that law. That would be a very hard
law not only to pass but also to enforce. But
you're pointing out something interesting, which
is politicians have lied for a long time. But
there was a different type of lie that was
normalized by Trump. And so before Trump,
politicians would lie, but most of the lies were
things like, you know, I lowered the deficit. No,
you raise the deficit. And it's like,
well, it either went down or it went up,
but you could sort of massage data and figure out
some narrow definition to make what you're saying
marginally plausible, where it's not an out
and out lie, that type of lie. You're saying.
Speaker 4: There was more nuance.
Speaker 1: There was more nuance to the lies,
and they were a different type. It wasn't like,
Oh, I have a different name and I had jobs. I
did right? Trump normalized a different type of
lie and the types of lies that George Anthony
Devil there Santos has been telling are the
types of lies that were normalized by Trump ism.
As far as the resignation part, I mean,
listen, Republicans don't seem to want to
force a vote on his resignation and they have
the majority. So it's a very tough situation.
Speaker 4: Right. I feel like I don't
know how we protect democracy from
corruption with this two party system.
Speaker 1: Right. And, you know,
it's a small margin in the House. And to some
degree, Republicans might be thinking, well, if
we force Deval, they're out or George or Anthony
or whatever you want to call them, all of them,
if we force them out and then we lose one of the
small margin that we have and then maybe someone
dies or resigns or whatever, and then all of a
sudden we may end up losing control altogether.
And I think that that's their primary motivation.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Yeah, It's the president.
It's a huge problem. I don't know. And I
don't know how we're going to dismantle
the two party system in America any time.
Speaker 1: Well, you've got to do campaign
finance reform. You have to change
how our elections are. You know,
there's so many things that have to be done.
Proportional representation would be a good step
forward. None. None of which are happening in the
next year and a half, I can tell you that. Emily.
Speaker 4: Mhm.
Speaker 1: Well.
Speaker 4: Well, yeah. It's frustrating
and I'm glad you're frustrated with me.
Speaker 1: I'm with you all the rest of
it. With you. I'm with you. Thank you,
Emily. Appreciate the call.
Speaker 4: See you later. All right.
Speaker 1: There is Emily from Colorado, capping
off, I would call it an eight out of ten today.
As far as calls are concerned, only three
bleeps needed and only two dropped calls,
which is really not bad. Really not bad. All
right. We'll take a quick break. We'll see
everybody very soon. And much more coming
up on the Friday show right after this.